hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm your
co-host Geo you're not Bart
did you just burp in your mouth yeah I
totally did that's disgusting why where
else am I supposed to burp ladies don't
do that you didn't hear it
you know I could you know I could you
know I could burp on command
oh that's not me
okay well I guess I'm not as special as
I thought I was what other [__] dream
do you want to kill of mine
um I'll tell you you're living a dream
because you're with me is that what is
that what's happening yeah well I know
someone that wasn't living a dream
growing up who you that's true
at what age which could dive right into
it dive at what age were you in
preparation to becoming a monk
preparation that's what it felt like it
felt like that's what your mom wanted
you know what's crazy
um I actually brought that up with my
mom when I was a kid
when you were a kid yeah it's so weird
you brought it up when you were a kid
yeah oh okay it's so weird because
um she at first was like yeah
and then she was like no
isn't that weird yeah what no what what
the [__] yeah yeah what brought what
okay and then back up you son of a [__]
okay you asked her what
I think I want to be a monk
so you didn't ask her you told her yeah
you wanted to be a monk the [__] at what
age
I forgot but it's got to be between 8
and 12. 8 and 12. so we're talking about
like third grade five six Junior High
yeah yeah
and why did you want to become a monk
because you're like that's the only way
I can escape this [__] to be honest
yeah no seriously yeah to be honest that
was your oh cause that's all you knew
well so this is what I understand right
and this is what's really unusual
um I think it's very unusual for kids to
sign up to be a monk for a day
or a month for a week or month or two
weeks they sign up yes or to be signed
up it's very unusual
um but adults some adults will do it so
enroll in Heights
well I used to be able to go like this
now it's like
really far but in Roland Heights or not
Rolling Heights I'm sorry Hacienda
Heights there's a big ass Temple over
there very very famous temple called
shilai Temple
and over there they have a bunch of
different type of services and
ceremonies that you can sign up for
um and a lot of them are more like
religious based right like if you're
Catholic like you know you have like Ash
Wednesday or you have mass or you have
like different things that you do and
you have like these ceremonies
over there
um you have all of the typical ones and
then you can do a sign up to be
a monk for a day so I would say that the
layers go like this sign up to be a monk
for a day
then you can do something where you sign
up to be a monk for two weeks
then you can get ordained by the five
precepts
and then precept like a preset is kind
of like a law almost like a Commandment
that you will forever abide by oh and
then so one of them could be your
vegetarian okay right so I'll never eat
me ever again there's another one um I
don't know how to say it in English but
there's one that's like a bodhisattva
precept which is like right underneath
the Buddha in that precept you got to
get incense Burns so you'll get it on
your forums like what about the ones on
the hip uh that one is going to become a
monk but this is like some gangster ass
[__] so if you want to be a gangster
Buddhist you would go all the way up
here and they would s you in the arm
okay and [__] sign up for [__]
like this
I've done all the way up to the fifth
preset
okay so what's the first one so the
first one is the day yes A month second
one is two weeks two weeks and then the
one then you go okay I'm gonna take in a
vow and you took a vowel I took a vowel
what was your vowel can you share it or
is it like a wish no I I can as we talk
about it I can see if I can remember it
but I'm sure I break all of them okay
because I'm pretty sure I jacked off a
million times after that because I don't
think jacking off is one of them
um and then the the then you have the
booty side for precepts that you'll get
ordained in so you stopped at level
three you're level three Buddhist yes
you're level three monk yes or not even
a monk yet no on the way too yeah but
regular people
dabble here you know the Casual Church
the Casual Temple goer is not even any
of these the people that go every Sunday
or the people that go just for the ash
Wednesdays of Buddhism Judaism whatever
um a Muslim like whatever they're
usually playing in this realm yeah
there's this entire other realm that
people don't
don't really dabble in yeah and um
as a kid my mom signed me up for it okay
so okay as a kid when you're eight or
even earlier yeah I think as early as
eight I started I did my first one okay
so when you're eight at this point are
you getting in trouble a lot yeah I
started getting in trouble and she's
like Buddha please come save and first
grade that's when I first got here I
know you're your own technically I got
in trouble in kindergarten remember in
kindergarten lincolnburg no no in
kindergarten I didn't speak
English and then so they put me in ESL
and a bunch of class full of other
Chinese kids and then my mom went to
like open house or whatever and she was
like wait why is he in this class he
speaks perfect English he goes well he
doesn't respond and he goes he speaks in
perfect English and then he was like do
you know yeah I do you're like get your
ass back out of there so I think I was
just [__] around too much so in
kindergarten I was kind of like [__]
around and then first grade is when I
first got expelled from my first school
okay got it so was your mom doing this
to save your soul I don't know how
Buddhism works I'm only relating it to
Catholicism I don't know I don't know if
my mom conducted exorcisms on me like at
home I don't know if she thought wait
you can't just [__] graze over that
[__] chill the [__] out okay oh [__]
okay my bad okay
what the [__] so she conducted an
exorcism on you yeah what age
um all just all under 10. it's a blur
but all under 10. I think by the time I
hit 11 she's like ah [__] this none this
[__] works
okay and is it like a conventional
Christian Catholic so the one that she
would do she would like sit me in the
chair like you know my mom's house is
very different right most people don't
have a [__] giant altar in their
house and the TV on 24 7. yeah my mom
has a giant altar with [__] candles
and incense and all kinds of shoes she
has like a mini temple in her house
in the mini temple in our original house
she would sit me on a stool and she
would pretty much like do laps around me
while chanting for like 30 minutes
straight and then while waving incense
and then she'll have her own holy water
splash to holy water like if there are
any demons or ghosts attaches this guy
let please let him leave please my mom
sounds ridiculous yeah and if she would
just go around me and then she's like
chanting and splashing holy water and
I'm just [__] sitting there like all
cold and [__] all drenched I'm like I
don't know hopefully I mean when you're
a kid you kind of believe it you know
when you're a kid you're like [__] maybe
I am possessed like get out get out I
want to get in trouble
God damn okay so the exorcism didn't
work obviously
so then her next I don't know obviously
it's not going to be in this order but
it just makes sense in my head then
she's like I know well I don't know if
it's a progression like that the way
you're laying it out I see I don't know
if it's like I have a troubled kid here
are my steps to fixing him yeah yeah or
is it yo this is like my rock climbing
and I'm a single mom and it's gonna be
hard for someone to babysit my kid for a
whole day yeah might as well have my kid
come with me yeah yeah you know I mean
like I don't know the intention yeah you
never asked yeah I never I never asked I
was not smart I'm a kid so I don't know
I mean now dude yeah obviously yeah I
never I never asked her what the
intention was or how we got there yeah I
just know I got there and then when I'm
there like for the whole day there's
zero other kids in the program you know
there's usually like so let's go back
yeah um got it on the exorcism it didn't
work
um we don't know why she sent you to
monk school it could be because like you
said
um no babysitter Hobbies or this
[__] possessed I can't deal with
it yeah because those are a bunch of
different timelines and intentions I
don't know if they line up like that I
see I see okay so
did she tell you you were gonna go to
monk school was she like hey today or
like was there any prep yeah it would
just be like it's called bhagwan's idea
uh it's the day One initial just be like
hey tomorrow we're gonna block one side
here whatever and I'm just like
all right you know or I'll get my ass
beat so I might as well go okay so what
was that like day one you show up so
it's tough you um
you show up like late at night yeah and
at that time like midnight probably like
nine or ten oh why because you you want
to show up during a time of Silence to
kind of like absorb you into the whole
like thought and Vibe of it so when
you're in this the rule number one is no
talking
how do they receive you is it all
written it's all hand gestures
so there's no talking allowed it's
complete silence for to at least 24
hours
so when they come in what if you talk
what happens do they [__] oh that I
don't know no one no one broke it no no
one broke well fine but your trouble
yeah you're possessed you're trouble
that's how much I stuck to it why what
made you stick to it why did you respect
that and not even not your mom that
that's a good question it might that
might even be a result of ADHD where I
was like oh this is a cool challenge let
me try to see if I could zip it for a
whole day oh okay you know so so maybe
that hit the dopamine like oh this is
crazy so yeah like you would go in nine
or ten and there's all these like like
Buddhist barracks
behind that Temple so you go in and then
they kind of give you like your ropes
your sleeping sheets and your mattress
and you kind of just receive it and then
give you a mattress they hand you I mean
um
because as you're saying yeah a queen
size it's a waterbed holy [__] yes she
has like the [__] these guys are buff
the other person's inflatable
no yeah um and then you kind of you know
how like like uh kind of ants just
following a line yeah yeah it's like
that so you just show up and then things
are just happening and then like this so
everyone knows which room to go to and
then so me and my mom are obviously in
one room because I'm a kid [__] like
seven eight years old me going and then
it's they already let us know like
there's signs on the wall like it's uh
um what's the what's the how do I
translate it because it's not like
it's almost like terminate
terminate speak it would be like the
direct translation like your your
language your speaking has been
terminated
like signs all over the wall so you
don't say [__] so we go what's the point
of that
I need to like you know no what the [__]
is like Center yourself
like close off your senses
like like uh don't be a [__] Latin
[__] you know what I mean like what the
[__] is that like
I'm gonna [__] kick you in your
stupid jaw all right I'm gonna align
those [__] that underbite is gonna go
backwards it's gonna go back in yes Mama
thank you yeah all right that didn't
work out all right all right because I
wanted to [__] cause you pain not
make you cosmetically [__] beautiful
no but that's um yeah it's like
like whatever expressive like oh did you
try this is so good or like did you hear
what yeah like shut the [__] up no no
noise pollution yep like Center suck
your senses out boom and then
Eyes Only on nose tip or eyes on uh
hands together so when you're walking
around now you're either your hand tells
you that is the guy just pointing at all
the rules
no they're like so once they receive
every everyone and everyone's kind of
like in some sort of formation they just
lay down some of the ground rules
speaking
um yeah only one person speaks the
leader obviously and then that's it so
when you're walking around you have to
walk around like this why what's this do
it's some sort of like I don't know
Buddhist circulation and like Rarity Zen
and like what hand goes on top of what
uh right goes on top of left and go like
this and so when you're walking around
you only walk around like this you can't
swing your arms nothing like that and
you're always walking in a very solemn
um uh way you know almost like the way
like religious figures would walk where
they kind of have like this type of pace
yeah like where it's loading where
they're like
like a very like ground yourself deep
diaphragmatic breathing type of like way
so either eyes on the nose
like this you're looking at your own
nose or other people's own nose
you're just looking down so you guys
have such little noses you don't even
see it
yeah right there
you just walk everyone I don't really
see my tit I just see like oh I guess I
do
the figure of speech okay no one has
Asperger's when they're trying to be a
Buddhist monk the [__] no one's going uh
it's excuse me but my nose is small I
cannot see it everyone goes eyes to the
nose and there's like everyone just like
this already
everyone got it okay maybe Asians are
smart maybe you'd ask the stupid Latin
questions there you know what you
[__] what hey why are you doing
like that why are you doing like that
I'll just copy you you did it no I saw
your hair like this yeah my fingers
I knew you're a blonde for a reason no
oh
okay so eyes on your nose
got it so eyes on your nose or either
eyes on your under palms or you're
walking around like this so immediately
like when you if you could think about
that your whole
behavioral vocabulary is muted like this
that's right sucked out no wandering
eyes you can't be like Oh shut the [__]
this Shrine looks sick none of that you
can't be like yo what's that person
wearing or what's that person eating or
what is that what kind of texture is
that like your normal wandering eyes of
absorbing the world nope Center yourself
so Eyes Nose either walk around like
this like this speaking has been
terminated that's like the first within
the first 30 minutes those are the rules
we all get in formation we take our [__]
and then we go to
um you stick your mattress yo take our
[__] comforter whatever and then um
we go to the one that's one day we all
sleep in the same room there's like 30
strangers you all sleep in the same room
so everyone goes and do their rollout
beds or whatever and you organize are
you in the same room oh just because
it's a fast thing probably to get you
used to what like a monastery feels like
everyone sleeps in the same room
I think probably in the beginning phases
yeah so we all rolled out our [__] and
then we're all just kind of like you
know like [__] what is it like double
Lotus whatever they call it where you're
both feet are like this if you can make
it then
you do that position
and then so that's like starting and
then um and the Nightfall comes so
everyone goes to sleep everyone shuts
the [__] up no talking no nothing and
you can only imagine as an
eight-year-old this is like the most
boring most controlling most
unstimulating [__] in the whole [__]
universe and you don't even feel like
you belong because everyone looks like
they're [__] 50 years old or above
okay so that was the receiving part what
does the morning look like what time are
you waking up so morning you wake up at
four
okay so obviously I probably could have
been six two or six four if I didn't
have so much sleep deprivation yeah but
we wake up at four and then the first
thing we do is you go down to the bottom
of the mountain so you've been to that
Temple right it's [__] huge you go
down to the bottom of the mountain in
formation
and uh you do this thing where you like
take three steps and you bow to the
ground like knees on the ground forehead
to the ground like that I call them
Buddhist burpees so every three steps
you do Buddhist burpees while you're
chanting like these uh like um Buddhist
[__] chance or whatever and you go
from the bottom all the way up through
the main gate through the center
Courtyard to the top gate
and you know how long it takes
I think by the time we're done at 7am
holy crap hours
so like in the previous episode where I
was like talking about just quit no
everyone does it
no one's crying uh maybe people step out
I'm like Oh my back or whatever and they
[__] go to the side or whatever but
I'm with my mom so not only is it I'm
doing this I know if I have a peep
[__] Palm strikes are gonna come out
of nowhere you know and we're in an
Asian group so I ain't still in no child
protective services or whatever so I
just got to go through this whole [__]
yeah so like
um yeah three hours going all the way up
to the top
and I'm [__] like seven or eight
years old and you're just doing this
knees three steps knees forehead on the
ground and then come back up and you
keep going all the way up to the top and
mom thought that was cool for you huh
I don't know I guess so but like in that
other episode I was talking about how
like like
when I get beat like I've been able to
kind of almost separate myself from
um my body yeah I think these were like
the little steps that got me there
because I've been in places that are
completely [__] horrendous that I
[__] hated that I didn't want to be
in so how do I survive a three hour
thing at eight I'm probably playing my
own cartoons in my head while I'm doing
these things you know
[__] okay so now it's 7am
now what happens so 7 A.M you go then we
all have breakfast and when you go have
breakfast it's a very like it's even
harder than the military because at
least in the military there's a work
time break work time break like that so
like when we get to like let's say ciao
and boot camp when you're done which how
everyone goes outside and then pull up
time during pull-up time you can't like
yeah what's up player you can't talk or
anything but you kind of have some free
time shake it out you got Shake It Out
time there's no shake it out time you
walk up to the front you bow whatever
bathroom break I guess just shake it out
time for bathroom and then you get a
formation we line up to go inside the
Buddhist dining hall and then there's a
specific way you line up
kind of like snakes and then
um the food comes to you and then
there's a specific way you eat you have
to bring the food up 90 degrees like
everything is 90 degrees
you don't ever bring your head to the
food because that's an animal so it's
always food to the face and you stay
like super upright like this you hold
the rice in your hand like this and you
have a chopstick like this
and then because you know when they're
Buddhist and you're trying to be like
holy and [__] like that everyone's
trying to out holy each other so
everyone's trying to be like very like I
believe in saving the world and
resources yeah whenever everyone's done
with their food everyone's taking tea
and pouring it under dish and their bowl
and like drinking all the soy sauce like
to be like to show that like I'm super
grateful everyone's trying to outshine
each other with like how like which is
funny like when I was a kid it's so
ironic because I'm like I can see what
people are doing and I'm also
participating but I can see what people
are doing but I'm like but if we're not
supposed to look at each other and we're
supposed to be here
then where does this like Jones's
competition come from yeah yeah because
you would see people go like
and then the other person next to him is
like
like that you know and I'm like
everyone's trying to out boot at each
other oh my God people are gonna be
[__] people okay
okay so got it on the eating and then is
there like a specific amount of time
that you have to eat
um kind of it's not it's not short it's
not like boot camp like like you only
got two minutes scratch this [__] down
you have someone yelling at you it's
just leisurely time but it's not like
eating and talking and having a good
time or you like chill with the elbow on
the table fight the whole time perfect
form up and over up and over like that
you know
yeah yeah your mom still eats like that
perfect like 90 degrees and then after
you're done then we all stand up
together we all file out and then it's
like our first service so we go back
upstairs to where the big Shrine is and
then we do our chance for whatever for
an hour and and like and [__] like that
and you're doing what is that chant like
like what is that so you have like a um
what I believe because I haven't visited
that those materials in a long time what
I believe is you know how like
the original probably like Christian or
even Catholic scriptures are probably
all Latin well actually they are right
because when we go to Italy they still
say it in Latin
though then we had the anglicized like
King James version so now when you guys
are reading stuff or even when you're
reading Psalms or singing Christian
songs
[Music]
it's not a Gregorian chants no
um
the Buddhism stuff I believe is in
Sanskrit
which is like the original Asian
continent language probably predates the
Indian language I believe
um they use the Chinese phonetic version
of it
so you use Chinese words but you're
really saying Sanskrit
and when you're reading or when you're
like chanting all these things I don't
know what any of it means because it
just sounds to me
you know like one of them would be like
this one is for
this one would be for a something that
you would chant if you saw something
pass away in front of you and you're
trying to like help release them from
this world it would go yeah
that sounds crazy yeah so it'd be like I
don't know what it means I don't know
what that means they're just sounds like
sounds to mimic Sanskrit and it's crazy
that I'm I haven't been to that world so
you can see how ingrained this [__] is
in me like that whole phrase I have
memorized and I haven't touched it in 20
years that is nuts yeah that is nuts
because I'm sometimes I you know
sometimes [__] happens or you get scared
and like you want to do the [__] but
what is it the Lord's Prayer The
Father's prayer I don't know I didn't
yeah like give us our daily bread yeah
yeah that one and I always forget it I'm
like Our Father Who Art in Heaven I'll
be
they cannot come down
okay maybe I do know that one but yeah
yeah not like that at least that's words
it is words my shit's [__] sounds and
[__] but I've done it so much I
memorized the sounds so one of the most
famous ones is
um in Chinese is called uh Ami tochin
and the Ami torching when you read it
beginning to end non-stop at the pace I
just read it it's probably 30 minutes
long
oh my God it's 30 minutes long just at
that pace that I just read it
that thing as a kid I had it memorized
that's how many times I've said it do
you think though because now working
with taika it probably wasn't even that
hard for you to remember
because you're a kid kids it's [__]
hard oh fine to remember imagine
30 minutes straight
imagine how many probably hundreds of
thousands of words and how many times I
had to do that yeah that's crazy
that's like um I don't even know how
like how long Martin Luther King's like
I have a dream speeches yeah but like
imagine you memorizing that how long do
you think it'll take you to memorize his
that speech [__] a week
if that's all I now imagine you're eight
yeah no I'm not it's gonna I'm probably
never gonna yeah you have to have done
it thousands of times yeah so that's how
long I've done it so yeah so you do that
yeah you do Amit
then you chant like I mean you feel so
suffocated just listening to your
stories yeah then you do I mean tougher
for a [__] long ass time and you do
like these like almost like um remember
the snake snake game on like Nokia like
a figure eight not a figure eight you're
just going through all the aisles oh
like the snake game yeah and then so
you're just chanting and walking and
chanting and walking and then you sit
down and you chat some more and then you
you cross your legs so what's the point
of this the monk be the monk for a day I
think like
this from a scientific point of view or
from what point of view religious like
what what's the point of it
um I would say I would say from a
religious point of view maybe to see if
you like it is this the next step you
want to take do you want to know what it
feels like to be part of the the clergy
I guess uh from uh from a more
scientific point of view maybe it's a
good detox from The Real World oh like
sensory deprivation right it's like the
same reason why people like going going
camping it's like why do you want to go
camping you're just gonna get [__]
dookie nuggets and you're not gonna
shower you're gonna get sand in your
eyes yeah yeah and charcoal on your
fingers but people like that because
they get to detach from Electronics from
TV from the mortgage taxes daily
stresses they're like they feel free in
nature right yeah so I think this is
from a scientific perspective why people
like to do it over and over they
probably feel the big detox
from the stuff that normally like clouds
them yeah like the demons in their own
mind because you don't have room for
that you're just sucked in yeah yeah
yeah okay so now there's Mass so you do
yeah the Buddhist Mass you do that and
that's probably like two hours long no
yeah because you read that whole [__]
book and then after you read the whole
book you do the [__] little snake
[__] and then after the snake [__] you
sit down and you chant some more and
then after the [__] chanting then you
have 30 minutes of meditation what and
then you're just sitting there like this
with your [__] double Lotus if you
could do it and you're just like this
why 30 minutes
I don't know that's what they tell you
or is it just no like it just stops and
it's just quiet for that long it's just
quiet for that long
yeah and everyone's just sitting there
and then pretty much now it's like well
I guess I don't mind it as an adult but
I think the Suffocation for me where I'm
like oh God I can't breathe like I keep
moving my sweater because I feel like
it's choking me just listening to your
stories
uh just trying to think at eight what
the [__] was I doing when you were a
monk
eight years old fourth grade uh School
during the weekends I would wake up
um and go to ballet class
that's what I was doing I'm talking
about so that's what we're doing on
Saturday because these things are on a
Saturday yeah yeah so I'm doing on
Saturday yeah wake up early in the
morning and I love ballet that's it was
so much fun and I saw my friends my wife
is [__] with you but no really that's
what I was doing and then
um go home and just kind of veg out at
home and then Sunday morning rolls
around Sunday morning cartoons a little
bit of Soul Train
is dope okay it's the Soul Train will
play
maybe on Saturday but yeah I just
remember like it was just chill yeah
that's what I was doing I remember
showing up at school and they're like oh
I saw a beauty and the beast on ice what
did you do I'm like
a monk for a day
okay so uh two-hour ceremony 30 minutes
of meditation yeah the whole thing is
like two hours oh got it yeah okay
so the first meal was like your
breakfast yeah and then now you have
kind of like a um
like a what's the word like intermission
kind of like community service rehab so
like so everyone has like an hour and
then everyone's assigned a theme to do
to contribute to the temple uh so
whether like you're sweeping here but
it's a sh right it's not gossip time
it's like yo did you did you like that
tofu it's like oh that's vegetarian by
the way obviously it's uh it's you're
doing your thing like this guy's gonna
go polish that doorknob this person's
gonna sweep over here this person is
like pulling stuff up why are vegetarian
why are uh Buddhists vegetarian
um so you know like the one of the
center pieces of Buddhism is
reincarnation
so you reincarnate into
animals or whatever right so why not
plants you don't reincarnate to plants
no they don't consider plants like a
living thing
they consider so only animals are living
they consider they consider Gods living
things they consider what's a god
uh like a in Buddhism greater than human
a greater than human being
okay so in Buddhism if you look at the
so if you put the Buddhist lens on right
in the Buddhist lens I believe there are
three levels
three positive levels the three positive
levels are human as the bottom one
um and then there is I believe some sort
of like like Angel type beam and then
God
so the Christian God
in from the Buddhist perspective will
still reincarnate
but they the way the Buddhists view it
is that Buddhism is so fast
that in your Christian story God is big
in your story in our story God is this
small so when God says he's going to do
this for a million years in the Buddhist
view that's millionaires is Tiny so in
the Buddhist view God in a million years
will still reincarnate he still will
have to pay for the things that he has
done
oh damn that's how Buddhist views it so
there's three levels there's like
there's uh humans there's like Angels or
something and this I don't know the the
word I don't know the words in Chinese
so that I'm kind of butchering their
translation and then there's Gods then
below there's so these are like the
three Earthly creatures and then there's
like the three unearthly creatures and
so it's animals and then there's another
one where it's called like uh like you'd
be turned into a demon you know the last
one is hell
oh so so it's so you will reincarnate
and the reason why they don't eat living
things is whatever you're eating could
have been someone else's mom your own
mom
because you don't know if you're from a
past life do you know what I mean
because we're all reincarnating so we
don't know who runs into who so that's
why they just lay off of not killing any
uh living animals that's why like milk
is okay technically because you're not
you have to kill anybody eggs are okay
you don't technically have to kill
anybody
yeah I mean eggs you kind of are
stopping it
no they laid him already
yeah but not to the full term or
whatever it's called no they're like
non-jizzed on parts
because if you jizz on them then like
your chicken [__] on them all right
bro you don't got to call it jizz cream
pie
not even a cream pie
okay got it
so those are like that's like the six
levels pretty much and then so
um yeah that's why you don't you know
that's why it's vegetarian okay so now
we're at
the community service part
um everyone and how long does that take
I don't know what was yours they would
assign me different things what were
some of the things like sweeping or like
just being a messenger taking a stack of
like papers from here to over there
putting decorations on how did they tell
you they just hand it to you yeah and
how do you know where to take it
oh and then the person down there is
like you know like it's pretty like
unless you're an idiot you kind of know
what's happening yeah
um like if someone hands you a broom
you don't go like let me scratch my back
with it you know you're like oh okay
you know you just start [__] sweeping
God and and do you remember how you
would feel during this whole time were
you just like bored out of your goddamn
mind or were you just like I mean
this is what the [__] my mom does so I'm
just kind of used to all of it I would
try to find ways to try to kill time so
like obviously mine is a little bit
harder because if they give me a broom I
can't just go off and sweep my mom's
watching me too so she's like you're
sleeping next to me
I'm a [__] so I'm like sweeping
so I actually have to sweep so sometimes
I just try to like go in the bathroom
and then like count the tiles or
something so I'm so [__] bored you
know so I gotta go pee I'm gonna go sit
on the toilet I'm just like turning the
towels one two three four six six seven
eight nine ten like that
and all I guess I count all the towels
go back outside
oh my God okay
so now the sweeping part happens at
around like
yeah like pretty much right before lunch
okay do the same thing for lunch the
whole
snakes file in eat [__] 90 degrees
whatever all that [__] and then after
that then there's kind of like a nap
time
but then it's like Snap time so everyone
goes back no [__] what else would would
be of course I don't know I thought it
would be like hey halftime take a little
break you know like don't don't have
your heart up in your chest I'm like no
you know and so we carry that whole vibe
into everyone's single foul line back to
the place you're supposed to sleep so
everyone's sleeping like
you have to sleep in a certain position
well you're carrying that Vibe into it
there's no rules but because of
everything we just experienced no one's
like
oh you know like [__] like that and
like two pillows all comfy nah
everyone's like [__] it's time to sleep
so
[__] vampire
D you know
or if we give them [__] like
yeah like [__] it
ah damn okay so there's your did you nap
yeah I probably knocked the [__] out
right so [__] tired so then that's
nap time what happens afterwards napping
during the meditation I was probably
like
I know
doing that you know
yeah so then what happens after you wake
up
so after you wake up then you got and do
they wake you up afternoon ceremony or
you just kind of hear people kind of
slowly no there's like a uh like
different Buddhist instruments like ding
ding
everyone's like okay time to get up was
that were those instruments played
during like lunch time you know how they
have like the cow yeah that kind of
stuff there's they play it during lunch
time they play it during ceremonies
they play it during the uh
the bow all the way up to the mountain
because like ding it's like he tells you
what steps to take and then they're
chanting along you know damn
[Music]
okay
you wake up and you do what
so you wake up then you have your
afternoon ceremony it's like another two
hours long
okay yeah and then you have that
and then and now we're talking about
three o'clock yeah okay and then so you
do that and then I think do you know
what time it is at all other than the
sun obviously no not really there's no
claw it's like a casino well there
probably is but you're not supposed to
look at it remember eyes on the nose
yeah
so you can't be like like mid meditation
and like
you can't be looking at the the clock
like the way a fighter does in the UFC
you know I'm like
you can't you're just you're meditating
right everyone's meditating like this
so if like a [__] opens his eyes
like the person who's leading it is like
looking at you you know like oh [__]
they don't play
[Laughter]
yeah you better close your eyes you
can't be like like everyone's like
meditating and you're like
you know didn't like like look it's like
what the [__] going on
yeah
so now we're talking about maybe three
o'clock four
second ceremony
what happened then some more like
afternoon rehab [__] community
service type [__] then you have uh
dinner same thing and then at night like
a two-hour speech from like the head
monk I like about life lessons and stuff
like that
okay and then you gotta go home and then
oh no you you uh oh no
yes and then you get to then you get to
go home you hand back the message by the
time you go out you go home then you're
like it's like [__] like eight or
nine o'clock at night [__] okay so now
with the two week one did you do that
one so the monk for a day I've done that
multiple times
like I I don't know how many times I've
done it but multiple more than five more
than five for sure no
no no no
food yeah how far it's not one of those
like oh I did it one time it's like I've
done it multiple times and then the two
week one I've done multiple times too no
the two week one is the exact same thing
on steroids on steroids with a little
bit more free time in between where I
think people get comfortable because you
know when you're on the first day it's
like super like um
what's the word rigid like best behavior
yeah then people loosen up a little bit
you know so maybe like halfway through
it
you'll be like oh I saw like your your
son's like kind of sleepy like maybe you
should give him some tea like put their
Whispering like that so there's a little
give you caffeine no no they're just
like but they'll just have like little
Whispers now oh you know
so that's two weeks like hey tomorrow
morning when we go early in the mountain
it's gonna be really cold so wear extra
jacket like like there's like a little
bit more of the small talk but it's
still pretty similarly structured
oh my God and now you have your own room
or is it still with everything that one
you have your own room and you're with
your mom I'm with my mom and how is that
with your mom and my mom only going to
room and then we're like whispering to
each other okay good because I was like
is she still holding that in the room no
and um imagine like a big ass [__]
Airbnb with like I don't know eight
rooms in it so people will share and
then there is a kitchen in that house so
when you're off duty so technically
you're off duty as a monk at night when
people run into each other and there
they will whisper so like let's say you
know my mom's always drinking hot [__]
which I'll be making like hot tea or
something and if someone else that's
part of the program walks in there
excuse me
okay so you have a little bit of small
talk like that
sounds very
okay don't do that
because I think for them they're more
actually like like
I can't really put your son through this
[__]
you know but then I think instead of
saying that they go oh your son's very
cute they always say that because I'm
the only kid there there's no other
[__] kid there dogs oh my God yeah
okay so then there's the one day the two
week what's the third one the third
level the third one is the five precepts
oh that's when you what is that you take
a vow of
but is it after doing the two weeks
oh no no so they're just separate no no
I know but is it like so the five
precepts or whatever what is that like
then
that is I believe like a two or three
day service
for how long is a service like [__]
48 Hours 72 hours morning till night for
for three days
non-stop no you got to go sleep and
stuff
so it's ceremony so it's wake up
ceremony or breakfast ceremony lunch
ceremony shut the [__] up and what's
happening in the ceremony so these ones
will be like the first day is like full
repent you know uh let it all I [__]
up this is what does a kid have to
repent I don't know stealing yeah not
listening to their parents but full
repent the first day running into dude I
mean about a seven thousand times up and
down Buddhist burpees and about a
billion times a repair and repent then
the second day is kind of like I guess
the uh absorbing of like Holiness and
like you're in your in your reading all
these scriptures and stuff and then the
third day they give you a special robe
because now you earned it and you get to
wear a special robe uh you don't keep
the robe you keep the Rope oh cool where
are your robes it's at my mom's house
and you probably have like 30 of them I
got quite a few of them
oh my God they definitely don't fit
anymore right but I had a bunch of them
do you have to pay for all this stuff
that I don't know but I'm sure you do
I'm sure you do right
if you got to pay for a powerful
competition I'm sure you gotta pay for
these things right right right
well I just see I see churches and [__]
is more of a communal thing like a
community thing so yeah but I mean I get
it there's material cost nothing is free
yeah I forgot what let me let me see if
I could even look it up but there's like
five Buddhist precepts let me see
five I don't even know if that's their
English word oh yeah it popped up it is
here we go you ready yeah the first one
is refrain from taking life
not killing any living being so you take
a vow of that so no ants no flies no
nothing no mosquitoes so you guys do
consider insects and stuff like that
yeah so I broke that a million times the
other one is hey I don't do that I mean
I try not to I try not to too but I mean
I [__] hate mosquitoes number two
refrain from taking what is not given so
not stealing
so if someone doesn't give it to you you
can't take it so no stealing
number three refrain from the misuse of
senses
so not having too much pleasure
and the senses are eyes
nose mouth ears touch what's the nose
smell no I know but what what what
technically so technically no perfumes
really yeah because that's that's
Indulgence
okay mouth I mean gluttony food all of
that I get it ears like too much
beautiful music I guess no yeah
like to use it just to hear but I've
been when your mom was here you
shouldn't be listening to music like all
day long like the eyes okay maybe
pornography was the first thing I
thought of but what else with eyes it's
too beautiful
just keep staring at your nose
technically you shouldn't be wandering
around all the time like you shouldn't
be like indulging you know you should be
looking at your eyes just for what you
need but what if you need to be vigilant
I guess that's what you need it you need
it yeah but you should be looking at art
all day I guess
yeah then like Avatar I think it's like
I get it okay you can't be [__]
putting on 3D glasses go whoa what the
[__] is this
like that's that's technically yeah you
can't be [__]
like [__] Hans Zimmer is [__] I
bet your mom when she was living with us
not that your mom's just mental at all
she's the [__] best but I'm sure
she's probably like man Mexicans are
savages look at this chick I would come
out and I'm wearing all my body splashes
and like my perfume and stuff and like
my cool clothes Tyga's just [__]
glued to watching Spider-Man yeah [__]
like that um I'm in the car picking you
up but from the airport blast inside his
playlist
she's probably like
oh [__] Savages yeah [__] started
seeing when she got happy too though huh
[__] started singing when she started
getting happy too
she was singing see too much pleasure
out the mouth so that's number three
number four refrain from wrong speech
so you don't ever want to speak ill you
don't want to talk [__] you don't want
to gossip or conspire yeah yeah yeah you
want to be passive aggressive you don't
want any of that stuff
that's no no these are all great by the
way and then the last one is refrain
from intoxicants that cloud the mind
like drinking weeds ecstasy or whatever
all that stuff hot chicks hot babes yeah
technically I believe there's even five
herbs you're not supposed to it's not
listed in here yeah yeah yeah but like
remember the Buddhist like garlic and
like onion green onion like those things
I believe are like some sort of
aphrodisiac so they could be altering so
you can't be [__] with those two
because garlic will [__] [__] you
damn hey you want to buy some garlic oh
[__]
yeah
maybe not yeah remember that remember
but what about your mouth that's another
sense
um remember that that vegetarian
spot the Chinese spot
vegetarian Chinese spot Monroe Park yeah
happy family happy fam I love that place
I love that place but yeah they wouldn't
use any of those they don't cook with
any of those uh I don't know if you told
me someone told me
um they told me that that they don't use
anything they don't use it onions they
don't use uh garlic but it's delicious
damn and neither do any of the Chinese
vegetarian temples they don't cook with
any of that stuff either
which is crazy because a lot of the
temples have bombed vegetarian food
I wonder what the other four are if
Garlic's one of them garlic is what do
they do when they drive through the
[__] what's that City Gilroy yeah
what do they do they just take a detour
oh it goes this uh
wow shutting it out so then this is a
lot of repenting that you're doing yeah
it's a day of repent day of cleanse day
of like re juvenizing
um
okay and then you had to give something
up you said
no oh not not at this time no so this is
level three
two weeks five five yeah so this is the
this is the third level yeah and that's
where you stop that's where I stop the
fourth one was gonna get like incense
burn and [__] and then then it goes from
five precepts to I don't know how many
maybe ten ten now and then that one
that booty sought for precept one you
have to be vegetarian
oh
no it's not this one you don't have to
be
oh
how does that work well this one it's
you can't kill an animal but if it's
killed already you can eat it oh I see
but then the other one you must be
vegetarian so your mom is number four
surprisingly she never went through with
that one but I believe she lived the
life of one I don't know why she didn't
go through with that one you should ask
her and kind of put it put the pressure
on her like yo I did it at eight yeah I
did dude imagine like
um this is something I do think about
obviously I'm speaking from a Catholic
perspective here because that's the only
religion I really was immersed in and I
wasn't even immersed that much
um my mom didn't really like the
organized religion part of it like where
the where the civilians are running it
because there's just so much corruption
and you know kind of like we were saying
where like
um everyone's trying to up the Holiness
of themselves like with each other
uh so so she never really enforced it or
emphasized it like super crazy for us to
do that because the Catholic
uh priest per Church
they're technically normal people right
what does that mean oh like they can get
married but they don't go home to a fan
do they go home to like a family and
they have kids and stuff I believe or do
they live there no no I believe so I
think they they might rotate but I might
not be the best person because I know
when you're a pope you can I have no
idea right I have no idea oh okay yeah
it wasn't super emphasized but just the
the the part of like
yeah you can check it out
um pull it up Jamie yeah pull it up
Jimmy Bart
um but what I'm trying to get to is
wouldn't it be nuts so okay let me
backtrack a little bit more for us right
now we haven't put taika in any of it
because you're Buddhist I'm Catholic so
taika we haven't really made him go to
like make his first communion or we
haven't baptized him I don't know what
also they can't Catholic priests cannot
marry
oh well maybe I'm thinking Christian
they can be married before but once you
become one you cannot marry
because I'm thinking Christian or
pastors also because they're supposed to
be celibate
and that's where all the corruption
comes with all the little boys your
little sick bastards yeah
yeah when they're just Unholy [__]
deprived sick bastards so the priests
are they the who you call like hey
father I have no idea like Father Joseph
possibly I guess so maybe that's
Christian I really don't know I see
um
what was I saying oh yeah so with taika
we've never really enforced your side or
my side this is my question when uh
we get baptized
like at like an infant toddler
um uh age like months we get baptized
what do you guys do any of that no you
guys are just born
you it's uh you don't need a Costco card
to be in it
okay like there's no like where's your
card can't come inside dude my mom was
telling me pretty loose it's pretty like
that's awesome yeah I think the way they
view it it's
um
Buddhism feels very holistic
because it's not like this is our way
and if you don't go this way you're not
going this way it's not like that it's
more like
this is how it is
like the whole world reincarnates like
this is the way it is
so you do what you want to do but if you
want to figure out how to get out we
might be able to provide some answers
it's more like that that's so cool you
know how ours is
um
oh yeah so with tech we didn't do any of
that and like the older I'm becoming
obviously death
and like my my fate
is like getting closer and closer more
at the Forefront of my
thinking yeah
um like we just saw your dad you know he
just passed so this like we're at the
age now where like our parents are
getting really old and like just
these things are just more more bound to
happen so I'm I'm definitely more aware
and and like concerned of like
when I was younger I'm like I'm just
atheist or agnostic not even atheist but
I'm just agnostic like I do believe in
some higher something I don't
necessarily believe that it's this God
or that God Jesus or yeah like I just
don't I don't have a thing for it yeah
um but now because I'm older I'm going
but what if yeah you know like am I
doing my son a disservice now this is
the conversation I was having with my
mom and my mom obviously was very
excited to hear this conversation
because she's religious and she she's
not as devout as your mom
but she definitely has strong
spirituality and fate and stuff faith so
when I was telling her like you know I
think I want to baptize taika because
what's the worst that can happen right
like let's say
knock on wood something were to happen
to him
and he passes away and something then
it's like maybe this could have helped
him you know like him getting baptized
like the the rules that you're supposed
to follow maybe it is true we don't know
but if it's not true is it gonna hurt
him
we don't know right oh actually there is
a some some form of baptizing I just
realized oh so I guess that's level one
it's called
and I think that was so [__] I
completely forgot about it and the whole
other things that we talked about
okay what is it so it's just like a one
hour ceremony everyone goes and then
everyone you just sign up and then uh
everyone does it together so there could
be a hundred people that get done
together in that one hour ceremony so
you you kind of go you bow you do all
the stuff and you read the scriptures
and at the end the head monk like reads
out all the names of everyone that's
been on the list and then everyone is
spending like some incense and then now
you're like okay cool I'm formerly a
Buddhist wow yeah so I've done I've done
that too I assumed I just uh forgot that
damn so like now this is where I'm at
where I'm like hmm do I want to do that
with taika like I don't know
you know like I don't know what
obviously No One's Gonna Know this is
where the faith comes in
um but I'm like should I be doing more
for taika there's like times two where
I'm like
I want to start explaining to him like
um like he'll hear Jesus and like God
and stuff like this and I'm like he's
not curious enough but I'm also like at
what point like I'm just kind of in this
weird middle area with him I think we
just stay in the middle area if you feel
like a compelling need to do it let's do
it but I don't think but I think for
most people it's uh
it's what's going to be reinforced yeah
you know if it's like like if you're
like I want to get baptized because I'm
always going to refer to the Ten
Commandments or whatever
then okay cool it makes sense but yours
sounds way cooler yeah
the way the the philosophy behind it it
sounds
it sounds
more realistic or that's not even true
not realistic that's not the right word
it just it it feels like um or it sounds
like it aligns with my way of thinking
more you know what's cool about Buddhism
what you can be Christian and be
Buddhist too but you can't be you can't
be Buddhist and Christian how the [__]
does that work because remember in
Buddhism God that we know Jesus
is just on one of the levels um
so what's the highest level God the
highest level is Buddha and that's even
what God is trying to be
like they're trying to become
enlightened where they so those those
six levels I just told you about
um you're trying to get out of it become
fully enlightened and then so that
you're no longer in The Reincarnation uh
uh I see yeah
I see so then you're not even part of a
level anymore you're out because to be
part of The Reincarnation levels you
have to fall in one of these six yeah
and then
you can be anywhere at once you could be
like and even in the Buddhist scriptures
that we've been reading the one I was
saying that like takes 30 minutes to
read uh out loud word by word it talks
about how there's 10 000 galaxies 10 000
universes traveling from like it it
talks about all these worlds I don't
know how true they are but they talked
about they talk about like there's one
world where everything looks like it's
full of gems there's another world
that's like full of like the most
beautiful leaves you've ever seen and
it's just like
tens of thousands of different galaxies
and within tens of thousands of galaxies
tens of thousands of universes and tens
of thousands of planets of each per per
per every single one that's crazy
because in the in the
um in what you're describing it sounds
like we're still having a human Human
Experience right like
like um
um finding Beauty in human things
like leaves oh yeah yeah you know what I
mean like it's like gems like you would
think once we're out of this and you're
enlightened there's things that we just
don't even comprehend you're not gonna
have an emotional attachment yeah not
even emotional attachment but just
um
so the only way I can describe it is
like you know how every species sees
this world differently yeah some like
like bees see things in ultraviolet yeah
yeah yeah so like that's what I mean
like we're no longer human because we're
enlightened but in this in what you're
sharing shares and talks about these
galaxies and these gems and these leaves
and I know you're like paraphrasing or
you're just trying to simplify it
um but it doesn't sound like it's
something that's no longer human like
like they do uh no no what like in what
way like they'll be like um the water is
Flowing red and like rocks are floating
on the water like they'll describe
things like that uh like some alien type
stuff beyond the stuff that you're able
to comprehend and also keep in mind this
these scriptures are written 5000 years
ago yeah where they don't know that bees
can see
oh true other things you know they're
like it's literally like a Buddhist
giving a sermon and someone's like
writing
writing down like everything the
Buddhist is saying
that's kind of like the Bible too right
we're like the burning bush like what
does that mean is it like he was
tripping on me or like is it really a
burning bush like what what is it yeah
yeah yeah yeah got it yeah damn yeah so
it's like that and then uh so they talk
about like how big the world is and then
um so yeah so it's in Buddhism because
of that you can technically be Christian
and be Buddhist yeah that makes sense
because it's within the same world yeah
that makes it the way they see it yeah
yeah
um I told you this a while back but like
you know I've been so busy now that I
don't really think about it as much but
I think once My Life Starts slowing down
a little bit more I definitely do want
to start working on my spirituality not
necessarily tying it to a specific
religion but I do want to start building
that up with myself because I just see
so much benefit in it
um
um like it's a type of meditation it's a
type of affirmations it's a type of
um like communal thinking it's a type of
like really
awesome philosophy centered around like
love
you know that I like would you
started off with ayahuasca
oh I don't even connect that
because as you see it as drugs
and I know there's it's done for a
spiritual like it's a ceremony I don't
see that with like dead mouse and like
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I don't even
connect the two oh I see because I feel
like
um this is my own thinking and I don't
even know if it's correct because I'm
just kind of
feelings
so for me to want to take medicine I
feel I'm not medicine but um
Ayahuasca I feel like medicine plant
medicine I feel like I need to be in a
in a place where I already have like
I've tapped out all my natural resources
where I've done the studying I've done
the whatever rituals or whatever I need
to do and I'm really connected with it
and I've just kind of hit a wall and I'm
so in tuned with it and into it and like
and I'm and like my faith is really
strong in it that now I'm like okay now
I'm ready
but I feel like doing that first it's
just going to give me a disconnected
experience
that I just won't I feel like I won't
get the best out of it but who knows but
um
that's how I see it so if I were to do
Ayahuasca now it's for me to clean my or
like understand myself in this spot for
me I think I'm there that's why oh where
you're just ready like I feel like I've
been so invested in religion
that um the only people that I've ever
spoken to regardless of their religion
that I feel like are more spiritual than
me
are the people that have done it because
they've seen it ah you know like the
stuff that they talk about that they've
seen like oh man I've seen the [__]
fun Kaleidoscope it was [__] crazy
like that's literally the Kaleidoscope
[__] that they're saying in uh you know
like the thousands of gems the [__]
geometric shapes like like that kind of
[__] that's the stuff that I've been
reading in my scriptures so the since I
had that book memorized from paid from
the cover to cover
I think the next got it part the next
phase in my spirituality that's it is to
see it firsthand based off what I've
seen people talk about or you've heard
it yeah because I've been
I've been in it so much yeah I know
you've been in it you know and then I've
been out of it because I'm like [__]
this is [__] crazy like I'm So Young
um but if I were to take it to the next
level that would be the next level or
else everything else it's either I
become a full-on monk
or like
Ayahuasca like I've gotten to the brink
of it you know damned like I've done so
much religious [__]
that most people have never committed
that hard to I've spent spring breaks at
the the [__] Temple the temple you
know yeah as a kid damn I can't even
believe you did all this that's [__]
crazy at eight years old I can't even
imagine it but